Candid Truth.
>> Hello everybody. We're going to be
addressing music. As we look into this,
we're going to find out what Hollywood
and music artists and all these things
have in common that has actually
dominated the music industry for so
long. Particularly two individuals and
their tactics or methods of doing this.
The first would be
Max Martin, who actually writes all of
the songs and the lyrics note fornotee,
word for word, and Roger Love, who is
the vocal coach to all the celebrities
and music artists. He has had the most
top hits for 67 years of history. He's
literally the top hit maker and
songwriter of our time. And he has
worked with many many artists. So
Britney and Taylor Swift.
There's Taylor Swift.
Britney,
Backstreet Boys,
Lizo,
Carly Ray, Jeepson
Pink,
Ariana Grande,
Ellie Golding,
Justin Bieber, and Nicki Minaj,
Lana Anna del Rey feet the weekend.
Ariana Grande again. They've worked a
lot together. And Taylor Swift in Sync
again.
Taylor Swift.
Katy Perry.
Selene Deion. Wow. Okay.
Normani. Never heard of her but okay.
The Veronicas,
Britney Spears,
Katy Perry again,
Kesha.
Okay.
Demi Lovado.
Britney Spears once more.
Adam Lambert,
Bon Joy,
Ellie Golding,
Taylor Swift,
Katy Perry,
Lady Gaga,
Adele,
Usher and Pitbull,
Jesse J, Ariana Grande, and Nicki Minaj,
Britney Spears again, Ariana,
The Weekend,
Taylor Swift, Pink,
Britney Spears,
Backstreet Boys,
Selena Gomez. Okay, there's a new one.
The Weekend again.
Taylor Swift,
Britney Spears.
We're getting to the end very quickly
here. Robin,
InSync,
Ariana Grande,
Katy Perry,
Kelly Clarkson,
Taylor Swift once more, Backstreet Boys,
Britney Spears. Okay.
So, one thing that he is not telling you
is that when he began
he was actually I think just working in
sound booths and he might have had a
band on the side. But I remember hearing
um a video where he began to tell his
story and he started with his first
client and it was Ace of Bass, the from
what I understand the Nazi group that
wanted to get their music out there to
be catchy enough for people that they
would have fame and become popular.
So he did it
and
what he ended up doing was learning he
had a great gift. Many top producers
including Martin have been reported just
like he has to actually channel their
songs. He said it comes to him as though
it's a human fax machine. So in other
words, he does automatic writing or
invocation to get the notes and the
words at the same time. Now, artists
like Beyonce, Jay-Z, and even Bob Dylan
have admitted that they also do this and
feel possessed while creating music. Max
Martin is said to go into a sort of a
meditative state where melodic formulas
and lyrics appear to him. Whether
conscious or subconscious, this is
invocation as we know it, a practice of
calling upon spirits for inspiration.
What he has been known for is a
mathematical
structure to his songs. It's very
interesting because that's usually
linked with Pythagoreans who were all
about geometry and numbers. We're going
to learn a little bit more about some of
that, but his stuff is put together to
be hypnotic. It follows a melody plus
harmony plus lyric plus rhythm type of
structure which equals an emotional
trigger in the listeners.
Songs often follow the golden mean
pattern which I had never heard of but
it's 1.618
and the Fibonacci Fibonacci based
structure a form of sacred geometry. So
there you go. Pythagorean sacred
geometry.
He knows what vowels. This is his thing
of course probably from the automatic
writing and the demons.
He knows what vowel to sing on what note
to open the the throat chakra of the
listener triggering emotion, desire or
euphoria. What we know is that this is
actually a form of frequency based
enchantment. It's not just about making
you sing along. It's actually about
opening a portal in your emotions. So,
it triggers emotion which allows them to
plant messages into your brain and
normalize that kind of behavior. And
then they use repetition as ritual. You
will find that Max Martin songs repeat
their hooks, their choruses, and their
phrases as a ritual chant. In ancient
magic and witchcraft, repetition is used
to cast spells. The same in pop music.
Each hook becomes a mantra repeated by
millions, almost like a global
invocation, which is exactly the result
they wanted.
This brings us to Roger Love, the vocal
coach to the celebrities and artists and
even worldclass business leaders at this
point who are using his methods to
actually control people and make them
want to do their bidding or have favor.
So he has worked with Selena Gomez, John
Mayer and Gwen Stefani among others. He
teaches that voice is vibration. Roger
teaches how to shape the frequency of
your voice so that it bypasses the
logical brain and hits the emotional
core of listeners. This isn't just
communication. This is sorcery with
sound. He teaches how to speak or sing
in frequencies that make people feel
trust, love, lust, sadness, or even
submission. He helps stars find their
signature note, the frequenc the
frequency where their voice is most
powerful. Kind of like casting a spell.
This is aligned with ancient voice-based
enchantment like sirens in Greek
mythology
or priests chanting spells. Roger
teaches breath control as foundational.
But biblically and spiritually the
breath equals spirit meaning ruok in
Hebrew.
Controlling the breath is an occult
method of controlling spiritual
projection.
See in witchcraft they teach breath
incantations.
Breath plus intonation is a ritual
invocation formula.
And Roger helps clients bind emotion to
breath and tone and then release it into
others.
This is actually how this is how singers
and speakers enchant entire stadiums.
When we look at the occult and how this
works, each vocal tone aligns with a
chakra. It's a new age term for ancient
occult energy points. They aim for
throat chakra activation which is about
expression and influence.
A singer hitting certain pitches can
literally activate the audience's oh
emotional energy centers which is a form
of energetic manipulation. Now just
listen to this. They write in the occult
that the stage is an altar. The
microphone is a wand. The lyrics are
spells.
The lights and the crowd
are energy harvests.
This is why performances often include
circles, fires, and costumes with
symbols, the allseeing eye for one,
lightning bolts, the baffit horns, and
possession moments of alter egos for the
performers. Roger Love and Max Martin
have shaped the world as we know it with
all of these things being priests. if
you want to call them that of the new
global religion. They practice mind
control, enchantment, and spiritual
deception. What we have to understand
here is in Ephesians 6:12, it actually
says, "For we wrestle not against blood,
flesh and blood, but against spiritual
wickedness in high places." However, we
have to go ahead and address something
else. Mariah Carey is actually someone
we must talk about because she is the
second best hit maker and songwriter of
our day. She has been for a long time
and she kind of waits in the shadows. No
one really knows.
And the thing about her is that
she's been a key player the whole time.
We all just just thought that she was a
singer, but we didn't know that she
actually wrote songs for other people as
her biggest achievement. So, as as it
lines up, apparently Paul McCartney was
the best songwriter of history all time.
And then you have Max Martin and then
you have her. She is third in line to
being now that Paul McCartney of course
is no longer with us. I think I hope I'm
not saying that incorrectly. I don't
stay up to date on him. You have anyway
Max Martin. He's number one and then
Mariah Carey is number two. So, she has
helped so many of these artists. Her
rise and continued influence isn't just
about her talent. It's deeply connected
to spiritual manipulation,
frequency mastery, and even occult
symbolism. Okay. She uses a five octave
range, which for someone who doesn't
really know much about music, perhaps
you might be asking, "What is that?"
It's the siren range. Her famous whistle
notes and register, the runs that
transcend human norms almost. And it's
not just the training. It's frequency
manipulation. And it mimics the sirens
of mythology. In Greek mythology, sirens
use their voices to lure men to their
deaths. Mariah's voice is literally
called angelic, otherworldly, and even
hypnotic by music critics. And it
bypasses logic and stimulates emotions
and sexual energy, especially in ballads
and love songs. Her highest notes
activate the crown and third eye
chakras, aligning with the cult
teachings on spirit channeling through
pitch. Are you hearing me? There is a
science and an occult spirit channeling
through pitch, vocal tones, and
frequency. That's right. In occultism,
the higher the frequency,
the thinner the veil between realms,
they say. Mariah's notes open those
veils in her listeners. So, Mariah is a
co-writer on nearly every major hit that
she's released. She has been a rare pop
diva. That means she's not just a
performer. She's a spellcaster.
Her songs deeply tap into emotional
triggers of heartbreak, longing,
fantasy, obsession, betrayal. Her
frequently repeat key mantras like we
belong together, always be my baby,
hero, etc. She uses themes of love as
salvation, replacing God with romance,
which is a very Luciferian version of
worship. The Bible says about this that
that they seduce the hearts of the
simple in Romans 16:18.
So for Mariah Carey,
she talks about this in a way that's
very interesting. She says that she
calls herself Butterfly and even named
her 1997 album after it. While it seems
innocent, the butterfly is one of the
most powerful symbols in MK Ultra mind
control and occult rebirth rituals. In
monarch programming, a butterfly
represents the split mind. Post trauma,
one part beautiful, one part broken. In
the new age and theosophical occultism,
butterflies symbolize ascension and
becoming a god. Mariah said, "The
butterfly is who I truly am. It
represents freedom.
Freedom from what? She's referring to
being freed from handlers post trauma
and industry control, but yet she's
still in the system, which suggests that
she changed masters rather than escaped.
She also refers to multiple personas,
including Mimi, a more sexual, bold
version of herself. In interviews and
songs, she refers to being taken over by
emotion, energy, or a different side of
her. In a cult symbolism, this is called
walk-ins or spiritual integration, where
another entity uses your body or your
voice. Her concerts are drenched in
light codes, which is actually blinding
stage lights arrayed in means to
disorient and open the subconscious. It
also uses repetitive chants by the
crowd, worship style adoration, and it's
all Luciferian gospel, which pretty much
means when she is singing, she's kind of
having an attitude of I will ascend. I
will be like the most high. So, she is
actually what they would call a high
priestess of frequencybased seduction.
She's not just a woman with a big voice.
She's been used as a template for vocal
seduction just like Ariana Grande and
Christina Aguilera,
for emotional spellwork through lyrics,
and for divine feminine worship, the
goddess archetype in pop music. She
gives you just enough spirituality in
some of her songs to seem uplifting, but
just enough sensuality and false light
to draw your spirit away from the truth.
What we'll find is that in the occult
world, frequency equals access.
From ancient Egyptian temples to
modernday Luciferian,
mysticism,
sound has always been seen not merely as
vibration, but as a gateway.
A spell is literally spoken vibration. A
chant is sustained tone designed to
shift consciousness of your listener.
Music, tones, and harmonics
were believed to influence the spirit
realm, the chakras, and even call forth
entities. What the occult masters such
as Alistister Cwley had to say about
this
is that he taught that rituals must use
sound and vibration to be effective.
In magic with a K in magic in theory and
practice is one of his books he
describes a musical instrument such as a
bell, gong, or chant may produce a
vibration that tears the veil between
worlds. He explicitly tied certain tones
and intonations to astral projection and
invocation of spirits. He believed
vocal pitch
could summon demons or open portals if
used in a proper ritual frequency.
Cwley's sex magic, which is the core of
the Lima, the worship he created,
often combined breath, mantra, and tone,
a type of vocal energy, sex, sorcery.
Now we're getting into all kinds of
weird stuff, but that is one of the most
evil men in the world. He has the title
of being the most evil in the world. And
he says that
so we must then go ahead and listen to
what Helen Bloatski,
a new age writer, channeler, and writer,
uh, I already said that, has gone and
said about this
Blovatzky wrote, "Sound is the first
aspect of the manifested logos
logic.
Through sound, the worlds were created."
She says,
"She claimed the word
or logos was not Jesus, but a
vibrational principle,
twisting John 1 vers1
into pantheistic sorcery." In her
esoteric teachings,
sound and pitch were tools of
initiation, especially for opening the
third eye and contacting ascended
masters.
She also wrote that certain tones
vibrated in harmony with the aetheric
body,
awakening spiritual powers within, and
this is the root of what's now branded
as sound baths or healing frequencies,
if you've ever heard about that. It then
brings us to
Alice Bailey, mother of the new age
movement. As you see written there, she
was Blovatzky's spiritual successor and
UN affiliated newager. She taught that
music would be used to usher in the
Luciferian new world order. She says
music is the language of the soul and
can be used as a technique of alignment
with the hierarchy. hierarchy meaning
Lucifer and the ascended masters in
Bailey's doctrine.
She described the science of sound as a
way to reshape human consciousness and
destroy the old Christian world views.
Certain tones were said to invoke the
energy of planetary demons whom she
called rays like sun rays.
We can see that what she said was true.
In pop music and all music today, we
have found that
it has shaped human consciousness and
taken away the old Christian views.
We then have to acknowledge that Manly
P. Hall of the Freemasons also wrote
about this.
He exposes that the ancient mystery
schools knew about this.
Each tone he said in the musical scale
corresponds to a frequency of spiritual
energy.
When properly in toned or intonated I
guess [snorts]
it opens spiritual gateways.
He explained that the temples of Egypt,
Greece, and Babylon used harmonic
chanting and instruments to trigger
transances and possession.
He also warned that he who understands
the vibration of sound holds the keys to
the gates of life and death. This is why
pop music is ritualistic.
The artists don't even fully know
they're being used to unlock and open
those gates in their audience. sometimes
others have caught on and they know full
well what they're doing.
And then we have Albert Pike, good old
Freemason.
Also,
while Pike didn't write much directly
about music in morals and dogmas, he
actually praised the ancient mystery
religions and their use of chant and
symbolic music for spiritual
transformation and hidden
indoctrination.
He said, "Symbols and sounds conceal and
reveal the divine mysteries."
This is the duality of occult frequency
use. It hides from the uninitiated
while initiating the willing.
Do you hear that?
Through music, they're using it to
actually indoctrinate and initiate you
to being one of them.
And much of the occult world, as you've
heard,
is doing this as well with you
unknowingly.
So
when we start looking at high frequency,
we'll begin to understand that in the
occult, the higher the frequency, the
thinner the veil between the realms.
This is a foundational new age and
esoteric teaching.
They say the world, the physical world
that is, is a dense low frequency.
The astral spiritual realm equals a
higher frequency. So to contact spirits
or ascend, you must raise your
vibration.
That's why high-pitched singing like
Mariah Carries
and crystal bowls and Tibetan bowls or
bells and vocal overtones are all used
in modern occult healing and spirit
channeling.
Mariah's high notes therefore act as
vibrational piercing points that thin
the boundary between the listener's soul
and the spiritual realm. When combined
with emotional openness from the lyrics,
it becomes a form of sonic sorcery.
This is very dangerous because
when a listener is listening, they are
usually very open. Their heart is wide
open emotionally. It's raw, heartbroken,
has desire within it or loss or some
other thing going on. That means they're
open to influence.
It repeats and that mantra is repeating
in their head and it bids them to sing
along because their throat chakra is
actually responding.
exposed to high frequency pitches,
crescendos, and breathy tones. Their
spiritual def defenses are down and the
veil thins.
And the demonic influence can subtly
embed lies, lust, and deception
into their souls without them knowing
it.
This is why the enemy uses music more
than any other tool.
Now, [sighs]
when we look at this,
before we get to this particular clip,
we're needing to talk about
what God's frequency is. And that might
sound funny to some people, but he spoke
creation into existence. He knows about
vi vibrations and frequency.
He owns it. It's his. He created it, but
it's been hijacked by Satan.
But some good examples include David's
harp playing that drove away demons from
Saul.
Paul and Silas's singing in the prisons,
which broke the o broke open the prison
doors and their chains.
Worship music in scripture never
seduces. It actually delivers people.
In Isaiah 12:5, it says, "Sing unto the
Lord, for he has done excellent things.
Satan can only imitate this power, but
he uses it to ensnare, not set free."
but I knew it would come up and so I've
addressed it and we're going to watch a
little clip about how
this is
something used by the occult on purpose
to bring what they say healing is made
up of a sound bath
healing bath of sound over someone.
Oh, there we are. The melodies of the
singing bowls and the vibrations of the
gong
echo through the halls of the ohm center
on the upper east side of Manhattan
where I tried a sound bath.
Okay, I made it short for a reason. Um,
basically what happens in these sound
baths is they continue to make the bowl
vibrate just like the way you were
seeing it or the gong continually in
different rhythms so that it starts
opening up your and relaxing you to open
up the chakras and so on.
And so it just really
it works. It does what it's supposed to
do, but it actually embeds that message
like they said.
So, what's promoted today as healing
frequencies, like we were just talking
about, sound therapy or chakra
attunement looks scientific, but it's
based almost entirely on Luciferian,
Hindu, and theosophical
ideologies.
So the healing frequencies that we're
just talking about
originate actually from the sulfedio
frequencies.
They're claimed to be sacred frequencies
discovered by Dr. Joseph Pulio
in the 1970s.
He claimed divine revelation told him
that ancient Gregorian chants had
encoded spiritual DNA healing tones
within them.
Each tone is supposed to awaken or
unlock parts of the body or the spirit.
Examples just so you would know.
396 hertz is supposed to be used to
liberate guilt and fear.
528 hertz is supposed to you give your
DNA repair and be the love frequency.
963 hertz is supposed to awaken the
crown chakra.
You get the idea. But the problem is
this system is totally numerologically
based such as in the Cabala Hindu chakra
alignment and hermetic number magic such
as we've seen. It's not from scripture
at all.
The other thing that we've come to find
out that they've hijacked further in
this way is
binaural beats.
Now, one would know that
when you put in headphones, there are
different parts of that song playing on
one part, one side of your headphones
and the other in different frequencies
to make that surround sound kind of
happen for you. This is what binaural
beats are.
So they're used primarily to induce
altered states of consciousness.
They're used in remote viewing, astral
travel, and eastern meditation.
It replaces prayer and stillness usually
in the new age and occult worlds with
induced transances.
These originated in bon Buddhism,
Tibetan occultism and Hindu tantra.
Their goal is not healing in the
biblical sense. It's actually to align
chakras, awaken the condalini,
and merge with the divine energy, which
is actually Lucifer in disguise.
What actually happens in these practices
may be confusing, but you feel peace.
And in that peace, when you give up to
that music, your will, it kind of has
its way with you. It opens the soul's
gates, meaning the eyes, the ears, and
the heart, to spirits, but without
discernment.
It weakens the will, much like hypnosis.
And it stimulates the third eye, which
is called the pineal gland, which in
occultism is the portal for spirit
possession.
This is why after long exposure, some
people actually see visions during their
session, hear voices, feel guides or
entities around them and develop new age
beliefs even even if they started out
Christian.
What we'll find further is that this is
all based off of the fact that Satan
tampered. He tampered with the
instrument tuning.
The standard tuning for music today is
now 440 hertz, but historically it was
432.
Now there's a good reason for this,
which I will explain.
432, which it used to be, is
mathematically aligned with the
Fibonacci sequence,
natural harmonics of water, earth, and
the human body. And many believe it
resonates with God's design.
But in the 20th century, some Nazi
propagandist and occult experiments
found that tuning
should be changed to 440 hertz, a
slightly higher pitch that will then
create tension, mental agitation, and
spiritual dissonance for those who are
listening. Some researchers,
including a cultist, all have admitted
this was intentional. Changing the
frequency can make you change the
population's emotional state, said
Joseph Gobel, Hitler's minister of
propaganda. He was behind this as well.
Music at 440 hertz has now been shown to
increase anxiety and aggression,
diminish spiritual sensitivity, and
agitate the nervous system constantly.
This frequency is what dominates pop
music today.
And if you've noticed,
you go into malls, stores, grocery
stores, whatever have you appointments
at doctor's offices, they all
have music going.
And personally, I just wish it was a
good classical music most of the time
because I want to get away from a lot of
this
and instead they're playing this kind of
pop music that creates that tension and
problems within your body.
We have to then continue on with
explaining
that there is a way that music was made
by God and is okay to actually use.
Again, we see examples of David's harp
being played to drive the demons away,
the walls of Jericho falling,
and Paul and Silas being freed from
prison in their chains because of it.
Worship is important to God.
And so, we have to learn to use it the
correct way. Frequency is a spiritual
weapon. We have to realize this. Satan
twists frequencies to confuse, seduce,
and possess. But God uses frequency to
heal and free and revive. The difference
is all
in the spirit behind
the sound. Music tones and frequencies
should draw you to the voice of your
shepherd, to Jesus. And most of it does
not. Most of it leads to sensual
surrender and darkness in your life.
And
that's what it's doing. [snorts]
Now, for a quick review of how to
actually train your voice in a godly
way.
I [snorts] am no vocal coach, but I do
come from a musical family, and so I was
wondering this. I don't claim to have
any amazing voice either, but
I just thought that some out there who
do enjoy singing might like to know
that without the fluff, without
spiritualism being brought into this and
mysticism,
it's just a method after that. A method
that can be used to glorify God as well.
This would include number one, learning
breath control, which is the foundation
they say of knowing how
to not have a weak or erratic voice
tone.
So, use diaphragmatic breathing, sustain
a hiss, [laughter]
which I do not know how to do, practice
short bursts versus long bursts of
holds.
Resonance. Number two, resonance and
tone placement. You want a rich, clear,
natural tone, not thin or nasal.
And number three,
pitch accuracy and ear training.
You don't want to rely on autotune or
vibes in your voice. You want to be
exact on pitch.
You can use an a piano or app to match
pitch. Do interval trainings
and record yourself daily and listen
back objectively.
Vocal agility and control. This is how
fast, clean, and precise you can move
between notes. Now, I do know that this
is something I have tried. I need to get
better at, but it does work. So, that's
number four. Vocal agility and control.
Running triads, arpeggios, and riffs and
scales.
controlling your slides up and down
the notes in a large range.
Number five, range development without
strain is a key.
Expand your comfortable range. It says,
not just your reach.
Train with warm-ups of lip trills, siren
glides. I'm not sure how you would
change that, but
G or nay exercises.
Work on your head voice and chest voice
separately and then learn how to mix
them in. That's usually why most of us
don't have a filled out voice apparently
that is more rich. It stays up in the
head range or the chest range and it
sounds a bit too breathy or a bit too
nasly and something or other. Number
six, diction and articulation.
Every word should cut through the air.
No mumbling, no slurring, just a clean
delivery of powerful presence.
Number seven, performance, emotion, and
dynamics.
You can learn to whisper, sing, belt it
out,
speak, sing, and have emotion that shows
through it like sinceress,
anger, sadness, seductiveness, and
sarcasm.
However, you want to master vocal shifts
in volume
without changing pitch. Wow, that's a
hard one. Daily vocal warm-ups and cool
downs can be done.
But what we have to learn is that we're
not trying to actually manipulate
people's emotions, be breathy or
seductive. We shouldn't over sing it or
yell.
And we shouldn't copy other singers
quirks necessarily, especially if they
are from
powerful and popular artists in the
world.
Always warm up. Don't train cold, it
says. And don't record every day for
perfection.
Use playback for learning and not shame.
[snorts]
So
this brings us to the end. I hope that
that helps a little bit. Like I said,
those were some general tips that I
received from an online search on how to
sing the way God would want you to and
practice um to cultivate the voice in a
godly manner. But otherwise, I hope you
guys really enjoyed the presentation
information and thank you for your
patience. All right, I hope you guys
have a good night. If you want to
support us, here are our links and
different platforms for doing so. And we
do also have merchandise,
our shirts and other things on there.
And thank you guys so much for tuning
in. All right.